the sale mirrors are on a closed nature
reserve next to an airport we had
permission to fly do not attempt this
these are the sound mirrors on Romney
Marsh on the southeast coast of England
and the 1930s these were Britain's
experimental early warning system
against aerial attack and with the help
of few folks today we're gonna test them
now the small dishes over there they
were the first mirrors at this site but
sound wave from the base of a plane
engine have a wavelength that is much
longer than the whole surface of those
dishes so in 1929 this 200 foot wall of
concrete was constructed and to test it
we've got a drone now back in the 30s
they would have been microphones set up
all along the edge of this concrete for
court and those microphones were
specially designed and tuned to only
pick up certain frequencies the project
lead doctor William Tucker wrote that
they wouldn't react to a loud
airhorn nearby but when conditions were
right they would pick up the low hum of
an aircraft engine 27 miles out to sea
that signal will become the twitch of a
needle on a gauge in a control room
behind that wall butthole just there
that was the operators window now we
don't quite have that much base today
but take her up now our engineer Ben has
put a microphone here at the mirrors
central focus Thank You Ben
and also one outside the area so you can
compare
Sam
I'm sure 27 miles is asking a bit much
the drum is a lot quieter conditions are
nowhere near perfect there's a lot of
other noise from birds I think from
anything that's been built in the last
century and that mirror has 90 years of
damage on it but listen okay take it
sideways now the mirrors focal point is
different depending on the direction of
the incoming plane so the operators
could work out the direction of approach
based on which microphone was picking up
the sound so as the drone goes sideways
lessen the focus moves and that mic
doesn't pick up anything all right bring
your own now one point no plans for a
long string of sound mirrors across the
whole of the southern English coast but
there are a lot of problems with that
idea not only does it require a huge
amount of resources to construct and
maintain anything like that it's easily
swamped by other noise cars and trains
and new build houses drowned out the
signal any other engines in the same
direction get picked up too which meant
that you could either have friendly
aircraft patrolling or you could have
people listening at the sound mirrors
but never both at the same time and then
humanity invented radar and building
200-foot walls of concrete became
obsolete very very quickly so this was
never used in wartime but it does still
work there's a there's not much
technology that that can survive 90
years of decay but when your technology
is a massive lump of concrete guess
that's a little bit easier I'm talking
about the history of radar over on the
RF starship channel everything that
replaced this thank you very much to all
the team from that who helped make this
happen
humanity invented radar and building
200-foot walls of concrete
they came a little bit obsolete